[Music]
okay in porn addict news classic did you
supplement this yeah this from for me no
uh submitted by by Jose horny toe what
the horniest oh I've ever seen your toe
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of a vagina I don't
know I mean in so many people's mouths
you'd be surprised Michael he's got his
feet suck so many times for prank your
party when you play with us on TV shows
[ __ ] neato a study has found that
perceiving yourself as a porn addict
makes you more anxious about starting
and continuing a relationship so if
you're identify as a porn addict if you
don't then you're gonna [ __ ] up in
relationships we get anxiety yeah so
this there was this study at BYU where
they analyzed 350 men and 336 women and
what they found is that that the self
proclaimed porn addicts they they
identify with phrases or statements that
include I feel unworthy to go on dates
because of my pornography use [ __ ]
[Laughter]
porn connoisseur but porn motivates me
to go out and try to have a relationship
with something really he's not an
alcoholic he's a someone yet different
so what is there like where does the
line go who's a porn addict and who's
just normal like likes to beat it up
well the individual cuz its
self-proclaimed like if you think an
addiction is like classified as
something that affects your everyday
life so if you are addicted to a certain
substance or a certain active activity
and it [ __ ] up with you as a human
being like you don't go to work your
relations name your relationships then
is considered an addiction but if you
just whack off let's say like you wake
up are you jack off to go about your day
you go to work it's not really
considered an addiction so it's like
you're jacking off right now a little
bit socially acceptable a little bit of
an addiction now might be the best time
yeah
now I'll get it yeah I'll get it if it's
self-proclaim it could be someone that
just watches it once a weekend I go oh
I'm so addicted to porn yeah whatever
they see themselves if they see
themselves as as porn addicts then
they'll identify with these other
statements saying like I stopped dating
when I'm using pornography I have
withheld details about my pornography
news because I'm afraid of my partner
will react negatively so they're saying
like these people they're more god
they're morons I mean it's the sexual
activity is good and why is he putting
guilt on himself if he's too sexually
active that's what this country does let
the imagination roam and go and beat it
off and enjoy a get lost in your
imagination and then go and take care of
your partner in whatever way you be mad
if it's your thing god you beat it off
they're saying that there's like a lot
of religious individuals that feel like
they tend to feel this way because you
know it's morally wrong to pleasure
yourself so they have this guilt also
they feel they're like unworthy in the
eyes of God or something yeah that and
so like that translates who I'm unworthy
of being in the city
masturbating to porn is still like taboo
in just everyday society like even just
even normal black people obviously
everyone knows people do it but people
don't really talk about it that much
we're like yeah what do you search when
you watch porn like that's a heart
that's an awkward question that's 100%
true
yeah because guys guys would freely tell
their friends yeah I went on this date
last night we [ __ ] so hard they would
never tell their friends last night I
saw this point I jerked so hard it was
so good but that's like keeping it
inside when you're keeping it I think
it's a big cultural difference we're in
Finland were open and but here is like
when you have to be ashamed of that I
think I think we're more okay with
violence than we are with nudity yeah
it's also because of like what is
sexualized here and what's not so if
like culturally speaking there's a lot
things that are more sexualized like
like for example like even like in Korea
like your kid pays off in the middle of
the street it's just or like off the
road
she's a kid [ __ ] peeing on the road
like you're not looking at a little
baby's dick it's just like this little
baby's dick for the pink coming up out
there a year ago I went through this
coaching lesson in New York and they
told her that you cannot let kids take a
pee in the bushes you gotta make em pee
in their pants whoa no wonder they're
teaching and that's what the norm is and
then you know it's like it's a parent
walking into a room while the sons
watching you know come on would you
watch porn with your kids
I don't that wouldn't be comfortable but
that's fine to talk about it say it's
fine I mean everybody does it you don't
have to be ashamed of it well now I feel
like we're in the players were like
nudity not oh my god and he's gonna feel
bad about beating off yeah yeah and what
is it gonna do to them when they grow up
and they're you know become sexual human
beings and they have this guilt inside
them they're gonna become predators yeah
cuz everyone's doing it but if you're if
you're doing it and feeling shameful
every time you're doing it that like
you're experiencing shame
probably on a daily basis which like
psychologically it's gonna mess with you
you just told us that you jerk off every
day as often as I can yeah that's
probably why he beats it he knocks out
yeah it gets tiring I think I'd be
mortified that he didn't lock his
[ __ ] door I'd be like what the [ __ ]
man have some decency bro that's my
[ __ ] house [ __ ] what the hoodies in
my sock you guys ever do the circle jerk
what like your kid grows up and he says
like dad you know I think I'm a porn
addict
I'd say son it's good that you told me
about it now let's talk well how do you
why do you feel that way
how many times a day you doing what's
the tell me well what does make you feel
like you know is it a problem it's the
same thing if you got to go and check
the door lock if it's locked if you got
to go uncheck it every half an hour is
it really love then it's a problem but
whatever the problem it
I mean checking the locks or being a
germaphobe or being porn addict then
gives about tackling the problem being
able to talk about it and not feel guilt
or what if you just buy more locks for
the kids to play with so now you have a
door with like 50 lakhs on it is like
fine I don't want you to masturbate but
if you do I have attached 80 lakhs to
your north when you complete that you
can whack off as long as you want this
clip damn it
you wouldn't a masturbate anymore full
of blisters aha I think you'd have to be
a certain age though to even call
yourself a porn addict like even if a 14
year old kid is like jacking off like
like too much even if he is like it's
affecting his life like he's 14 years
old like that everyone's a born out of
thing he's supposed to be a party boy in
college like are like you could say like
an alcoholic you know like yeah as often
as they drink and his like hard it would
be to not drink for like a week in
college like but you're in college like
you're not an alcoholic you're just in
college like yeah I think at a certain
age it's really hard to read
and a lot of the people and
relationships you can tell it if they're
uptight and there's something more like
you need to [ __ ] let that inner
passionate beast out just enjoy lose
yourself in that moment and you're gonna
feel so much better when you do it in
within the boundaries with a partner you
know when you work out your muscle
confusion your masturbation confusion -
you got a [ __ ] trick your dick all
the time oh yeah it feels different -
try this one yeah follow us on Instagram
so you could spy on us like a sneaky
perverted neighbor because you know I
always post sexy photos for the last
video click over here
[Music]